pues hablemos primero
el candidato republicano él se ha
vendido como una ficha clave que conoce
el estado porque jugó en el equipo de
fútbol Estatal y de ahí de ahí se ha
pegado él para traer muchos de sus
votantes sin embargo ha sido fuertemente
criticado por que muchas de las mujeres
con las que tuvo relaciones Pues dicen
que aunque el que él le pagó los abortos
a pesar de que en campaña se declara
provida y contra el aborto este señor
habría entonces financiado varios
abortos de mujeres con las que había
estado y ese ha sido uno de los focos de
crítica del candidato republicano que
abiertamente Trump ha apoyado además se
le critica también que vive en Texas no
en el estado de Georgia Así que no es
muy cercano al estado por otro lado está
Rafael
el candidato demócrata que es un pastor
conoce muy bien la ciudad nació en
Atlanta es de Georgia y pues aspira
entonces a la reelección teniendo en
cuenta él ya había sido electo al senado
por dos años reemplazando el senador que
estaba antes en ese escaño y ahora
entonces pues aspira a quedarse en el
senado en Washington seis años más si
hoy al cierre de las urnas a las siete
de la noche y tras finalizar el conteo
pues eh Como lo indica las encuestas
queda otra vez Rafael en el senado para
seis años de mandato en Washington
Cristóbal cómo quedan entonces las
fuerzas en el senado si ganan demócratas
o si ganan los republicanos
pues ya los demócratas aseguran de todas
maneras tiene asegurada ya la mayoría
con 50 votos y el voto de desempate de
kamala Harris pero lo que quiere el
partido demócrata es precisamente dejar
de defender por un lado de kamala Harris
que tenga que estar constantemente yendo
al congreso a tener que hacer este voto
de desempate y por otro lado y es el
punto más importante dejar de depender
de El senador Joe manchin senador que
aunque sea demócrata normalmente termina
votando de El bando republicano y ha
sido una piedra en el zapato para el
partido demócrata en sus proyectos
políticos porque al votar republicano
tras tener esta mayoría apenas de un
voto del voto de desempate de kamala
Harris pues entonces el partido
demócrata siempre tiene que terminar
pues acomodando las leyes los proyectos
de ley a favor Y a medida de lo que pide
este senador Y entonces precisamente
este voto 51 Pues el partido demócrata
prendiera la independencia de no tener
que seguir acomodando los proyectos de
leyes a los caprichos según el partido
demócrata de este senador Joe manchi por
el estado de Virginia occidental y
tercero Pues porque en los comités del
senado pues tendrían la mayoría y avalar
y pasar los proyectos legales por los
comités del senado y las investigaciones
y además las aprobaciones de los cargos
públicos Sería mucho más rápido teniendo
este voto número 51 en el senado de
Estados Unidos